vendredi soir parc jean-drapeau pro
noire soirée de chéraga
dans cette fourgonnette un laboratoire
mobile a été aménagé et on est ici parce
qu'on va faire de la messe de substances
juste à l'extérieur de clôture de
l'événement pour les gens qui veulent
bien ou un service depuis 25 ans le grip
sensibilise et offrent de l'aide aux
consommateurs de drogue en milieu festif
ce nouveau service d'analysé gratuit et
légal
judith nom fictif il venu faire analyser
ce qu'elle s'apprête à consommer
pour le même temps spectromètre la
machine à me
saluer tous présents dans l'échantillon
à
ce nouvel instrument permet une analyse
plus poussée grâce à une exemption de
santé canada le grip manipuler et
redonner la substance aux consommateurs
après analyse et que j'étais capable de
trouver de la cocaïne mais aussi quelque
chose qui s'appelle la lidocaïne la
lidocaïne c'est un agent d'un couple qui
comme fréteur dans la coke
puis d'enfance alana j'hésite un test
pour détecter du fontanil est aussi
effectué il s'avère négatif c'est
toujours une inquiétude parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'amis parfaite qui ont tous
des problèmes at les 30 années donc je
trouve que ce service a c'est quelque
chose qui devrait se faire plus souvent
parce que l'udc c'est inégal les gens
ils ont terre
[Musique]
en général si on est présent si on a
beau service c'est parce que la
situation existe c'est parce que passage
à l'acte i lya ça ne va pas créer une
augmentation du passage à l'acte ça va
éviter qu'une personne qui passe à
l'acte soient seules isolées et sans
outils au québec six organismes ont reçu
l'aval de santé canada pour effectuer
l'analyse de drogue le grip souhaitait
depuis longtemps qu'un tel service doit
faire dans le contexte d'événements
festifs et on a eu tendance
particulièrement avec la crise des
surdoses par exemple un petit peu oublié
peut-être cette population consommatrice
dans le sens où c'est tellement
récréatif qui de temps en temps qui sont
beaucoup moins au courant 2 qu'est ce
qui se passe sur le marché de la
consommation ça peut être un danger
aussi dans dans ces cas là pour une
personne dans sa prise 2
un sujet délicat pour les organisateurs
de ces événements
consommation de drogue est interdite
mais malgré des fouilles c'est une
réalité dans le milieu de la musique
électronique ça existe c'est une réalité
après ça mais qu'est ce qu'on fait nous
sommes proactifs et s'assurer que les
gens ont la meilleure expérience
possible lien qu'il collabore avec le
grès pour d'autres services les
organisateurs de picnik électronik sont
réticents à offrir un service d'analysé
à l'intérieur du site il ya un paradoxe
ok on n'est pas contre la vertu on n'est
pas contre le projet mais de 0,20 son on
assume ce fait alors que techniquement
tous étaient légales
chez fierté montréal pas d'hésitation
l'analyse de substances hao offerte par
le grip sur le site même du festival à
l'esplanade du stade olympique pendant
la pandémie sur tournée dans les
communautés de sgbt qu ia plus ça a été
difficile les gens étaient isolés on
nous pond parle de personnes
marginalisées quinté plus isolé que
jamais et oui il ya eu de la
consommation des preuves plein plein
plein plein d'enjeux de santé publique
la santé publique de montréal rapporte
une hausse des surdoses dans la dernière
année mais impossible de comptabiliser
les événements reliés uniquement aux
événements festifs à montréal la crème
du fentanyl est toujours présente on
associer cheval le fentanyl à des
drogues de
aux itinérants mais maintenant on voit
cette de laguiole beaucoup plus chez
monsieur madame tout le monde qu'on
n'aurait pas passé qui en avait consommé
c'est pas une clientèle opiomane
tellement dans les festivals de musique
électrique c'est un peu plus jeune
clientèle festive donc beaucoup
stimulant que kane speed méthamphétamine
beaucoup démené est morte depuis 2010
est la docteure marie ève morin
intervient dans les festivals avec
l'organisme projet caméléon c'est ce
qu'on cherche
l'analyse de drogue se fait par
colorimétrie une technique moins
coûteuse les moins précise que le
spectromètre
cette année son équipe a reçu l'aval du
ministère de la santé et des services
sociaux du québec pour effectuer
légalement l'analyse de substance c'est
steve l éclipse en outaouais le drug
testing ça n'augmente pas la
consommation salaires diminuent parce
que quand on a une personne devant nous
qui vient d'acheter du speed mais tant
pis nous fait réaliser ce qu'on écoute
on pense que des traces de fentanyl là
dedans il consommera pas l'analyse de
substance devient si façon d'établir le
dialogue avec la personne qui consomme
québec suit donc les traces de la
colombie-britannique où l'analyse de
substances en festival se fait déjà
depuis plusieurs années une manière
d'éviter les mauvaises surprises et de
réduire les risques de surdose
[Musique]
de l'eau
tu
[Musique]